foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is Black Panther wakanda forever and we
are spoiling the heck out of it you guys
top of the show spoiling the heck out of
it I was about to say something but I'm
gonna give you like three minutes
and then come back later once you've
watched them yes save this put this in
your watch later file on your YouTube
like it first like it and then come back
yes and there's no Redemption goal today
but hit us with your uh Black Panther
reconna forever questions we're gonna
try to get to as many as possible by the
end of the show but you guys know that
this is gonna be a pack show with a lot
of conversation yes we've got a lot of
stuff to talk about and we're gonna real
quick just hit a few black panther or
non-black Panther headlines yes
headlines graphics
there it is
um okay uh and you know this is kind of
other sad news in in a weekend a film
where we're kind of like mourning the
loss of like one of our cherished
portrayers of a superhero and Chadwick
Boseman kind of rough that we get news
of the passing of another of our
favorite superhero portrayers Kevin
Conroy the voice of Batman uh in so much
most famously Batman the Animated Series
but so many films other appearances
right he kind of passed sadly similar to
Chadwick Boseman from cancer I guess
you've been battling it for a little bit
but it was kind of a surprise passing
people didn't know he was sick
um so Tom and I were just talking if you
are of a given age
um and you know maybe grew up in the 90s
or or early 2000s like he was your
Batman's day I mean I feel like it's
like one of my like my main Batman
players of Batman he was he's the one
that we grew up with you know the one
that we we got to experience the lore
with because when growing up you didn't
have a lot of superhero shows like other
than animation with like X-Men animated
series or the Batman animated series we
were lucky to get a Batman movie every
few years we still didn't have a
Superman from the 70s that was the last
time we got to see with Christopher
Reeve so it's really tough I love that
in a world where you know there's
there's so many James Bonds there's so
many Batmans there's certain archetypal
characters that there are a bunch of
everyone's got their favorite everyone's
like you know when you say James Bond
people pick their James Bond but there's
always the who's your Batman and someone
might have their favorite movie Batman
but it's always Kevin Connor in the
conversation like there's always like
well you know Kevin Conrad right and
then I like like Kevin Connor is so much
a staple you don't have that with a lot
of archetypal characters because he's so
definitively Batman and I love that he
loved the character so much that he even
wrote on like he wrote a comic like
fairly recently he goes to these cons
and he talks about what the character
means to him it wasn't just an acting
job for him it was something that he
embodied and something that he felt
really special about and and that's such
a beautiful thing that he got to know
how much we all loved him like it's it's
really special that he spent so much
time at cons and you have to feel that
love because I feel like so many artists
don't get to know what their impact is
and I'm really just glad that we live in
an age where he got to know how much we
loved him yeah yes yeah so uh shout out
to all family fans admirers friends of
Kevin Conroy like uh more power to you
and rest in power Kim Conrad um and then
uh we're getting some early box office
members for black panther wakanda
forever uh of course it's printing money
of course taking a ton of money it's
printing its own money yeah yeah
wakandan wakanda into balloons
but it's it's
shaping up early to be the third biggest
post-pandemic opening after Spider-Man
no way home and Multiverse Madness uh so
far it's like tracking to do 185 million
dollars domestically here in the US
which is the first one did about 200
million domestically in its opening
weekend now that was a three-day weekend
and uh that was before the pandemic so
um still huge numbers obviously it's
gonna be a big success we'll we'll find
out more next week exactly how big of a
success it was we're excited um and
black panther one noted for its legs
that movie was incredibly strong in the
box office for a very long time so the
fact that this opened so close to the
original and the legs the first one had
I imagine this is going to do
gangbusters yes absolutely we're hopeful
of that because like uh the better it
does the better we do
hey hey okay you're correct no no but
also if if a lot of people are watching
it that means a lot of people are loving
it and having a great time with it and
that's what also we want that Kevin
feige was like oh it depends on how well
this movie does if we do a third one and
I was like does it I feel like you're
gonna do it anyway
it didn't come off the way I'm sure yeah
he was genuinely just like there people
were like we're getting the third one he
was like yeah I mean this one does
really hot like yeah absolutely and now
it's like opening night it's doing
really what's like destroying right
that's every movie right well if the
first one makes a lot of money we'll
make more it's a good sound bite to have
at the ready like how do I answer this
question like Kevin feige oh well you
know if a movie does well we'll make a
sequel like this yeah that's a very
Kevin feige answer yes
um and before we dive into our what kind
of forever discussion uh it's Friday
which uh we often do something on
Fridays called Fresh Face Friday brought
to you by geology our friends at geology
makers of fine skincare products like
this little guy everyday face wash hell
yeah
um this is a segment where we celebrate
a new face
in the MCU and this week we're
highlighting Mabel Cadena I hope I'm
pronouncing your name close there she is
who played nemoura in wakanda Forever uh
you may or may not recognize her because
she had a breathing apparatus over half
of her face
and was often paid
with like a
her headdress
you know what I'm talking about
I also love that it was perfectly around
her bun like you had the bun and then it
was just around it I mean of course the
characters in wakanda Forever are
perfectly styled and have like excellent
costuming and everything like that but
the the telecons and their costuming and
the looks just incredible but um this is
Mabel's First Hollywood film she's but
she's worked a ton in her native Mexico
uh including on a lot of titles in
Spanish that I will butcher but uh
Camellia la tejana la bandida okay uh
check out those if you enjoyed her work
in uh I don't know the last one because
it's El Bale like to dance uh de los
cuandro even though I I think 41 is
quonso why did I go with this
well you know one reason you went at
that the dance of the 41. you had a
chance to talk to her yes I did she did
I got to talk to her and did an
interview and it was perfect and she uh
it was with uh so yeah I got the chance
to speak with her and Alex linovelli and
they played nomora in a tumor and it was
perfect and we have a little clip here
that I'm embarrassed to show yeah let's
see what was the working underwater
portion like I'm sure by now everyone
knows this but she's the champ are you
holding the breath you know how long
Three Tomatoes in the house no yeah no
no you you gotta say that loud
six minutes you can hold your breath
underwater six minutes and a half it's
amazing work under the water you know
it's beautiful well to me it was
beautiful it's like you need to lose the
control it's like well I just need to be
relaxed I just need be focused and is
that okay and actually what we're coach
say you can sleep underwater maybe I
know I don't believe you no yes you can
sleep under the water and you never know
anything I can't swim I generally this
is insane to me went forward in the MCU
are there characters you would want to
fight now
huh
love to get into it with
a young man from uh Queens
who shoots a spider web
[Laughter]
I think you'll be a fun uh
a little action uh event oh my gosh
yes
before you guys can hear me I didn't
know the camera was on me
it was my first press junket I was they
you get five minutes and like koi told
me which I stuck in my brain uh you get
five minutes uh hellos and goodbyes are
included in the five minutes yeah that
walk-in counts I got like three
questions in and honestly I kind of had
this written thing to ask and then I was
like they're just so nice to talk to and
they're so beautiful so it blinded me
immediately and um but they were really
sweet and they were so nice and Alex
linovelli was he grabbed me into a hug
and was like be proud
[Applause]
and also a quick uh we're one degree of
a couple Degrees of Separation from Alex
who played a tumor and that uh I think
he's the same manager as Tommy bechtold
come on the show atuma do you remember
me yeah you've met her you know she's
safe and I will say that junkets are one
of the hardest things to do in our job
because you walk in blinding light
you're just meeting these people you
have to make them immediately
comfortable great body language the
whole time you look comfy you look ready
not to be uh Shady to any other person
that was interviewing them they were
practicing so much in the mirrors and
the hallways dancing back and forth and
I was like uh I think we could just ask
we only have five minutes let's just go
talk to them and I maybe I was under
under not dressed but under qualified I
guess no prepared yeah because I just
went in there and I just started talking
to them
and you can see um there'll be some
other maybe clips from those interviews
news that Eric is going to have in our
full film breakdown that's coming out on
the channel tomorrow but uh one thing
that definitely comes across is the uh
as Jessica pointed out the stunning
beauty of both those actors uh
specifically Mabel uh Cadena who is our
fresh face Friday nominee for this week
we're looking forward to see hinted at
in that last scene we see of nomoria of
both nomura and Neymar obviously gonna
be important figures we're going to see
more of her certainly in the MCU right
um and so uh you should check out
geology.com head over there take a
little quiz to figure out uh your best
skin care needs and the products that
will help you with that maybe to help
you have the glow of a
teleconil how are we what are the people
no tell us
put in the chat with your favorite uh
way to refer to them in an inoffensive
way is
um uh and uh uh head to geology.com new
rockstars and use our promo code
rockstar70 to save 70 off your geology
order that's it's an incredible
discount folks new rockstars 70 or sorry
Rockstar 70 promo code at geology.com
new rockstars but let's move on to our
wakanda forever discussion okay so the
final minutes of black panther ricotta
forever kind of presented us with three
future options for the leadership of
wakanda and I want to go into each of
them the end of the film leaves us with
the assumption that shuri will take the
mantle of black panther while I'm Baku
will handle the leadership of the
country itself uh at the end of the film
he says the Black Panther sends her
regards but she will not be joining us
today I'm Baku leader of the Jabari
tribe son of wakanda wish to challenge
for the throne who's gonna challenge him
I don't think it's anyone so worth
noting that he refers to shuri as the
Black Panther and only wishes a
challenge uncontested for the throne so
my first question is what is shuri's
role as Black Panther and MCU going
forward both in regards to wakanda and
the rest of the world
I see her as a symbol of uniting the
disparate tribes right like they've
already come together more than they
were in the first film but as we saw the
one scene we see of them in the the new
home of the Jabari is like kind of them
disagreeing about how to handle things
right they're like you're you're a guest
in my home let's figure this out but
then she symbolizes them coming together
literally by touch like they all touch
her and unite so I see that role they
talk about how the Black Panthers always
United the people so I see her as
needing to unite them and being that
symbol even if she's not physically
there so I think while omaku is actually
going to be king I think the Black
Panther symbol needs to be an important
thing in the world coming at wakanda so
like when we're gonna get this wakanda
show it looks to be setting up that
other world leaders and other nations
are going to be trying to get things
from vibranium like trying to you know
invade I think she's gonna have to be
you know outsourced she's gonna have to
be other places as either a you know a
new Avenger or whatnot wild he protects
from home can I counter that somehow uh
yeah I count it as a mouth I think that
she's going to be called upon later in
the future sometimes they're gonna be
like we need need extra help we're going
to need you and she's going to say no
but I also think in Black Panther 3 if
they get it sooner or later it's going
to be like Chi not if you notice in the
movie got a lot of the wakandans killed
when they were fighting on the ship
against the talokins and so the telokans
were regenerative and they were able to
come back but a lot of the wakandans it
went from like 100 versus like 10 left
so I think they're gonna remember what
happens in shuri's mind as the Black
Panther and how she let like hate really
really push her through and though she
came back at the end full circle it's
still like a lot of us died in the fight
that you had us go on and then you left
the ship and we all had to fight for
ourselves that's really important so I
think the Black Panther mantle is going
to be like needed by The Avengers but
then I think in wakanda they're gonna be
like well do we want to see it right
away again soon well it's interesting
because like the I think the face of the
black the back path or mantle becomes
like the face of wakanda I think is what
you know because without it that's when
people thought that wakanda was weak or
not you know or could be infiltrated and
have their vibranium stolen but now with
with an actual Black Panther in place I
think that's that's what how that role
is going to be served but it's
interesting because uh yeah we've we uh
you don't need to be the king or the
ruler to be the Black Panther even with
chachaka with t'challa we saw that and
um and it's funny because I was noticing
parallels with Thor how he didn't want
to become king he wanted to kind of
still be his superhero selfish same way
maybe sure he's gonna take that path and
not want to be the leader yeah I learned
that kind of a way yeah I think we're
seeing like there was a parallel there
between Black Panther and nomura right
in that like they were both powered
individuals who were both the hero of
their people and the leader of their
people right when speaking of t'challa
and the more right but like it seems
like both those roles are being divorced
for both characters right on the one
hand shuri and back we were kind of
splitting those roles one will be the
leader the people one will kind of be
the hero she wants to be in the lab
coming up with cool suits she doesn't
want to be passing legislation she
doesn't want to go to the U.N right like
uh and Old Spice commercials like
Valkyrie yeah that's right I mean
hilariously embaku going to the U.N come
on guys
I mean will he ever will he ever put on
a suit because I love the the dermalage
have their like sharp like flight
attendant looking like outfits right
they're not coming in there and they're
like Warrior GARP what is embaku is he
still have like a fur coverage and he
calls each of them a bald-headed demon
yes yeah he's got he's got a he's got a
piece of celery and a sweet potato and
he's just pointing at him um but uh uh
also I think and I kind of talked about
this in a rogue Theory episode that'll
come out tomorrow but like we're also
going to get that I think in the in to
locon in that the the bloom is off the
rose for the telokan people and no more
they thought he was their God he got
whooped on the beach you know what I
mean there would be a reckoning there in
that like I don't think he'll get to
keep lead obviously he's so powerful and
maybe the hero of the telokan people but
like you could see a tumor or somebody
else being like all right time for
somebody else to have the throne for a
little bit maybe some infighting
something like that I could see it I
would I would want it to be a tomb of my
favorite there's a lot of my favorite
Parts I will say that a lot today but
one big part that I really loved was
their Greatest Warrior being a Tuma
versus wakanda's best warrior yes and so
I just love that Dynamic of like these
people are too weak okoya you're the
only one that can fight me so I wanted
Tuma to be the next one that takes the
mantle for uh no more but also this
leads me to my second question you guys
will embaku have a larger political role
in the mcu's future or do you expect to
only see him in Black Panther related
titles I think Winston Duke wants to
play yeah
I think dudes want to see everywhere and
like I want that for him and I feel like
everyone loves amaku like there's a
reason we were like that guy's got to
come back for the next one so I see him
getting you know more exposure like Zach
I was also on Rogue Theory and I talked
a lot about uh Valentina uh Allegra de
Fontaine and how she is gonna like make
a mark in a lot of things and now that
she's like the CIAA like director and I
think her now like because she had ever
Ross who was uh treasonous activities
with the wakandans she will have to go
and talk to the leader of the World Cup
that's which is going to be on Baku and
I just want to see that Dynamic and I'm
like okay so we can see him be in the
voice of reason not voice reason but
being like the voice for wakanda a lot
throughout anything anytime they show up
at the U.N it will be in Baku
Baku brings uh brings Ross to the UN and
she can't do anything about it because
he's like this is my hand or like with
my interpreter or whatever he wants to
say just to bring around just to put him
in everyone else's faces like you guys
can't do [ __ ] that's a good question is
like they took Everett Ross from that
little prison box and now he's in
wakanda what is embaku gonna do about
that is he okay with that yeah he's
gonna be like take him back you know
what white wolf yeah
it's wild to think of like Ibaka running
wakanda but think about like he was
right about everything in this movie he
I mean sure he didn't take his advice
she should have she got a lot of her
countrymen killed right and his
maturation from the first film like I
love that his first film Arc was wanting
power and not knowing how to wield it as
maturely as he did here now he's gonna
have the power that he showed he's
worthy of and it's like it's he'll have
a three-act structure like because he'll
go from I want power I deserve power I
have power and we'll get to see how he
utilizes that it is a little bit it's
funny you just mentioned Valkyrie kind
of ingest but like kind of a similar Arc
right like uh her becoming a leader and
like earning that and rejecting it and
then well it's also he said it in the
movie that he was like I promised your
brother I would take care of you like I
would listen I would be there to listen
to you and I'd be there to protect you
so I'm like he literally went such a
full circle but I think it was that
moment of like uh him dying the king
dying to be like hey I need you to watch
out for my sister I even love that in
the the big you know nomura attacks
wakanda scene like he's out there
pulling people out the water keeping him
from drowning right like pranking people
with that
[Applause]
again my favorite part sticking his
staff in the water turning the boat he's
off
such a dumb move so uh for my third
question how soon will t'challa the baby
the son take up the mantle of black
panther if ever as Prince Will he take
control of the throne from umbaku or
will he get the get a house of the
Dragon style series Wichita sends a
dragon to kill him Baku or some [ __ ]
genuinely
um I'm just gonna say out loud on this
um I don't think so and I think it's
because you respect the Dead's wishes
and they didn't want the pressure of the
mantle on him so I don't think we're
gonna see baby t'challa ever be like the
prince or King unless literally uh shuri
dies and umbaku dies and they literally
are like we just need to start grabbing
people but I think Respect the Dead and
that was like his wish was like I don't
want him they just introduced Sherry as
a black panther I don't think where
she's going to need at least several
movies just even from the Marvel movie
making side I can't imagine them
starting a new black panther all of a
sudden and aging this kid up just so
that they could have a male black
panther you think they're gonna age him
up though I think they might put a
little Cassie Lang yeah it's gonna be
Catherine Newton
I am from um well like actually uh in
the ending explained uh video that's up
on the new Rockstar's Channel right now
Mt had like an interesting Theory like
because it is like this kid's six he's
not like close he's not like 14 where
you could be like oh the next movie he
might no no he's so far away from being
an adult right but like uh he pointed
out Kang Dynasty keng's out there time
travel is going to be a thing you think
he's gonna remorse them through a time
or we meet him older yeah actually like
cable style he just shows
yeah that's what they did in Lovecraft
country and I love that and I could see
that again doing it here with like going
in the future and then like reading the
book that your son made in its older
version also most of his names are
impactful right he's not only princess
Charlotte but his his Haitian Laurent is
a like uh revolutionary yeah is someone
who represents the Haitian people as
someone who overthrew tyranny right so I
could see them having him be an older
Laurent to the public and a Princeton
child in private until he has to reveal
himself like there might be a moment
where his like he's got a secret
identity effectively like a comical
character he might reveal himself to be
prince t'challa in a moment and I could
see that being a thing when he's older
like he might stay Laurent in public and
then become Prince to Chuck it was a
good idea of throwing him in at the end
credits but I also think it's like now
the doors open for her they can
literally take and use this as many ways
as they want and I would love to see
that version of going into the future
and seeing him as a what if Episode I
think that's an episode where I'd be
okay with like seeing it and like
feeling it because it is like they just
made sure it literally just they just I
still haven't even seen it it just
happened so that's why I'm like if it's
a and what if episodes can still become
reality oh they can come into the MCU
yeah Captain Carter hopefully I think
with season two they recognize how
important season one of what if is and
make their characters actually like
planted on the ground because Captain
Carter like died immediately but like I
think they can actually make story lines
out of these ones season one of what if
was one through three they've said that
season two of what if it's just phase
four so I have to imagine he's going to
be in it because of how much like
they're literally looking at the last
three years not the last 14 years right
so I have to imagine well there's 14
movies
exactly yeah
uh we're gonna uh get into a lot more
black panther we're kind of forever
discussion including some of your
questions but we want to take a moment
to quickly shout out uh our friends at
butcherbox who help us bring this
episode to you if it wasn't for them we
wouldn't be able to answer all your
questions uh Hey thanksgiving's right
around the corner I was thinking while
watching wakanda forever there was some
food in what kind of that at the end
happy wakanda we see some like grilling
of what looked to be chicken or some
other uh bird type food
there's some good looking it was
seasoned it had some coloration to it it
was over an open fire I got hungry
exactly give me that give me that look
good too yes
underwater papaya variant
um and also the seaweed on display guys
um varieties all kinds of salads could
be made from that but thanksgiving's
right around the corner and we're
talking turkey okay that's what you have
at Thanksgiving and you want a good
turkey if you're the one in charge of
cooking the turkey you got do a good job
you're going to have good ingredients
and the best place to get those good
ingredients is from our friends at
butcher box they take the guesswork out
of getting good Meats and Seafood and
poultry they send a variety of boxes
whatever you're into if you're into beef
or chicken or pork or seafood right you
could tell them that they send you this
like cultivated box of just delicious
high quality stuff all the full trees
free range all the beef is grass-fed all
the um Seafood is wild caught it is like
the nicest stuff it's good for you it's
good for your family it tastes delicious
um so uh they also throw in recipe
guides and little hacks so you're sure
that you're cooking it well because
sometimes maybe maybe you cook one
turkey a year and by the time November
rolls around again you're like I forgot
how I cooked this last year maybe I
didn't even do a good job last year
butcherbox can help you out we're big
fans of of all their stuff every time we
get a butcher box delivery here at the
office it's like hyenas pouncing on it
to be like I want the pork chops I want
the bacon I want the salmon
um uh so be your own hyena and sign up
today at butcherbox.com break room and
use code break room to get a 10 to 14
pound turkey free and your first box
they're just throw it in a big old bird
for free in your first box that's
butcherbox.com break room and use code
break room to claim the deal thank you
to butcherbox for supporting the show
um okay now we were talking about uh we
have a lot of other kind of theories
with the world of Black Panther and
things like that but I want to talk
about the actual movie movie of it all
okay
um who was your favorite new character
we met we met a bunch they squeezed in a
surprising amount of new characters into
this film easily Riri Williams Oh okay
stole the first time I saw it I was like
wow this character really stole it for
me but I also the second time seeing it
I was like it wasn't the character it
was Dominic Thorne she's so good she
delivered on that role that made me so
excited for ironheart to a degree that
now I'm like
hurry up come on and also just like I
can't wait to learn more about what she
can make and and a lot like a little bit
of time and then also just more about
her family because I want to know more
about her dead step dad I'm with you
with ironheart she uh when she came out
on stage at Comic-Con she was with like
Titans and she still had like a like who
is she presence like when she spoke in
the whole age stage but surrounded by
people we already love it's impressive
to be able to like stand your ground
hold your own and be like you know have
draw any attention when you're with
Winston Duke is next to you and he's got
three feet on you yeah I was so
impressed like this girl there's
something about her and then uh she was
at a couple After parties I went to and
talking to her about the way she
perceived the character was not only how
exactly I perceive the character
selfishly but also when she spoke in
real life she sounds like a Bendis
dialogue like Brian Michael Bendis who
invented Ireland has this like
pentameter to him he's got this like
Shakespearean Sorkin flourish and
Dominic Thorne sounds like Riri Williams
in my head so the entire time waiting
for this movie I was like riri's gonna
like if they give her enough time she's
going to steal everything and then she
did so my expectations for degree were
Sky High she exceeded them so I cannot
wait for the Iron Heart show yeah
awesome yeah well I'm gonna say then
someone different I want to say a Tuma
because oh I was expecting just like
some you know forgetful kind of villain
but even with the few lines he had he
give him some character and even how he
had a he would call out a coin it
reminded me of Bane just showing up and
being like you know I'ma break you and
then and then their fight even had that
like on the bridge it was silent I
remember you all you could hear was like
and it was like so good and so I was on
the edge of my seat the second time
watching it I thought about that that
bridge scene and like him putting the
staff in the ground and then whipping it
on an accordion I'm like it's silent I
was like you might not get up from this
like yeah and so his little he didn't
have that much screen time but made a
big impression on me and I and I could
see that hey this could go somewhere
because a lot of times especially in the
early Marvel phase movies you know it's
a forgetful kind of villain like you
know don't call anybody out but let's
say like ghosts it's like okay you're
gonna be in Thunderball it's cool
because I didn't really get to know you
or see anything about you anymore Batman
and the WASP but now it's like oh we
know who a Tuma is and if he comes back
and ends up being the big bad and uh in
the Namor movie oh that's okay I want
him to destroy everyone but Okoye like I
just want acquire to be clear like that
scene of him always fighting her was
like so clear it was like we already
knew she was a badass like this was a
match this big ass man this tiny woman
and they were still a match like maybe
maybe setting up a potential Crow
species love affair
all right no but you said you said a
movie you said like a spin-off you said
a spin-off well I I was saying like uh
there are two well okay we're biting
into a later question no let's let's go
ahead and jump into it like the two
spin-offs I selfishly want to see first
off I want to see uh IO Anika uh hot
lesbian uh Dora melange uh romance I
would like to see I would like to see
them fully explore that and see what
like their domestic life is like how do
they decorate what do they what are they
cooking for dinner
um I would like to see that and then
like a um I was saying like uh an
Opposites Attract kind of like even a
koye and Riri had a fun chemistry and
their scenes together
um and Baku and uh is a really fun Odd
Couple pairing like if that's who kind
of comes together to lead the country
and they're like they're kind of like
you know always at each other but like
in a really funny way I agree with that
I want Okoye to get her job back as the
general to embaku
and him be like you're nothing and then
they just keep fighting about it feels
better there's so much and also uh no
more obviously it was like crush this
movie man like every time that guy's on
screen you can't take your eyes off him
as far as favorite new character okay
real quick uh and and this is hard to
pick one it's also a two hours and 40
minute movie with a lot of scenes
favorite scene
hmm well since I just kind of just said
it I'll I'll throw it out there the
bridge scene but it's really cool but
that's when we got to see for the first
time really what are the talocons about
it and then then like so much happened
in that with them with their now they
they're with the language that they
speak with the breathing apparatuses
with the water grenades and then the
regenerating healing Factor like what is
even happening these guys are no one to
mess with holy [ __ ] that was that was
dope when they got in the accident oh
yeah
when I got in the accident that slow
motion water behind them exploding and
Okoye in the car flipping and uh sure
fly in midair energy Shield I still got
knocked out so sorry no go it's around
the bridge so I was no no not mine so
the scene around the bridge I also like
the the chase leading up to the bridge
going to the bridge scene because it
reminded me obviously the first film
it's got It's got some throwback
elements but then they also added the
fact that like this movie was much more
geopolitical drama than James Bond
action film the first film had you know
equal parts geopolitical Thriller
superhero film James Bond there's a
there's a bond element and and without
t'challa without Chadwick you did feel
the absence of the bond so I really like
that instead of going like the movie
didn't feel like it was missing an
element it felt like it consciously
chose to lean into a different tone
because of that chase scene for me
because I was watching that going
they're acknowledging this aspect but
they're not trying to replicate it
because they are missing their King so
even in the tone of the chase they use
different shots they use different music
they use different elements in Boston
which made me happy but that made you go
like hey this movie's not going to have
that third flavor on it don't look for
it that way it didn't feel like it was
just like oh we made a movie without
Chad MC it's a movie in honor of
Chadwick right which I loved so it was a
side effect of an action scene that I
don't usually get where I'm like a
plot-based tone element so that and then
the scene after uh with with Riri flying
for the first time where they all kind
of team up leading to the bridge that
whole dynamic again Boston bias uh but
like they they're literally flying
around a place that means a lot to me
and and it is a movie about home so like
I've been I've liked out drunk on that
bridge so many times and like to see it
like not while driving no no I want that
bridge while flying my iron suit he was
taking out drones no there's that
there's a concert venue called Middle
East downstairs Middle East upstairs and
the other side of the bridge and I used
to live on the other side so that bridge
was like a hope for the best Bridge so
to see like characters I love fighting
on a place that I consider home about a
home like it's the most selfish reason
but I felt home in watching these
characters try to find their home again
and that was really special and then
Wales jumping down the whales jumping
were great I have two but so I have two
because my first one again if you watch
my review on the channel I the the
characters it was the characters that I
love so much and they uh explored
emotion at a range I've never seen and
so Angela Bassett delivering that blow
to koi about haven't I lost everything
and I was like who I like it felt like I
was getting yelled at so I started
looking around the theater
that delivery three of like she was like
I I put my whole life into this I was
like she did and then she was like I
lost my husband my son and now my
daughter you are out of your mind uh but
then also my favorite Easter eggs to
catch because I got to see it a second
time so I actually were like looking at
Corners there's two times the news pops
up with Anderson Cooper the first time
we see that uh at the bottom it reads
that Scott Lang is on a tour right now
for his famous podcast and uh so that's
probably why we see in the quantumania
trailer he's always being high-fived and
on red carpets and doing everything and
didn't he have a book in Miss Marvel no
the podcast was in
the podcast okay sweet so that's what
he's been doing he's very famous the
second time is when Ramona dies uh you
see underneath it's about a legal thing
that happened in new Asgard now I say
legal thing because it had that it's a
split second they say Ramona dies and
then it turns off and all you see is new
Asgard court and it's legal thing legal
thing Jessica pay attention if it said
Court do you think that means it was
like legal like a legal court or do you
think that means like the court of the
king you know I immediately went to
She-Hulk and remember the person that
changed the faces I went to that and I
was like maybe they're talking about how
there's more people like that that are
just interesting duping people yeah or
it could go because remember the whole
sokovia chords I'm like we were
wondering how it works at new Asgard if
they count as new yeah yeah or yeah well
it was like because Newsies or not New
Zealand they're in um Switzerland wait
where is no it's in Nova Scotia Canada
such a deep dive to figure out for legal
law was uh if it they can still abide by
their own laws within sure if they're a
Sovereign Nation or whatever yeah yeah
yeah
I don't know where I got that because we
have some some wonderful Canadian
Chatters like Christian unpronounceable
and some other folks uh my favorite team
for that introduction to the chilocons
on that like mining vessel oh and like
how cold is ice they are and how like we
don't get good looks at them for a while
in there the siren call I had no idea
they were gonna do the siren thing how
creepy that was and they're cold-blooded
we see them like in a movie that like
often doesn't show a lot of blood right
like there's a lot of violence in this
but fight scenes that don't have a lot
of blood but like those are dark right
you know you know like the the Celtic
myth or the selkies how they call you
into the ocean to drown you like I like
that the Atlantic have this like selfie
aspect I did like that it was kind of
sirony where they were like we're not
mermaids but it's also like let's do
let's do it I got water stuff
something that's basically around here
real quick we we got introduced to
basically a us well a a synthetic
heart-shaped herb obviously but also
like the telokan version of the
heart-shaped or have some other kind of
glowing plant that grows in vibranium
yeah yeah algae bloom or something like
that that grows in vibranium rich soil
which one of those plants would you
rather take
I'm gonna go OG uh you know I'm not I'm
going non-GMO I don't want to
genetically modify heart-shaped I'm
going organic free range between last
three I thought it was just like the
heart shaper we have now or like like
era no you can't choose that one you
have to choose oh oh I didn't realize I
couldn't choose excuse me excuse me
way to take away the actual one yeah so
it's between uh this one the new one we
have yeah
they're both Monsanto herbs
um well I guess I'll take the corn syrup
uh
I'm gonna take the 3D printing because
that trust her is uh science all right
that's a good one
I would also take that one but that's
also because I just don't want to be
underwater yeah I don't want to be
honest it's very limited it is very
limited when you want to come out you're
like oh I can't breathe so I don't want
to really do it but I do love the blue
skin yeah yeah you know I I kind of I
want the water one you know
yeah you know and I like drinking a lot
yeah and also two-thirds of the two
thirds of the world's covered in water
landscape
or anything that'd be great we talked
about this briefly and I don't know this
so if you guys know the answer so he
they can swim in ocean water and fresh
water yeah yeah because presumably when
you first met Ramona and shuri that was
a freshwater river yeah right because
the elephants were drinking the water or
whatever right in the ocean yes yeah so
they could definitely do presumably like
some kind of Bulletproof Skin perhaps
because
they're they're textured you can't
breathe air but you know yeah and you
know there is a child can do which I I
assume I'm sure you can keep up and more
I imagine like if you're blending too
two sets of powers that's right so I
think sure this is going to be 3D prints
with a little extra juice right animals
did he get to ride t'challa and sure
none because the other tribe was the one
that had the Rhinos killer whales yeah
killer whales oh yeah that's true we
didn't see a great white shark animal
riding wow
also also with the heart-shaped herb you
get to trip balls you get to go get the
trip so hard that you see your ancestors
we didn't get any sense of that cousins
you really don't like that's right
I know there is a quick SNL sketch about
this with Keenan Thompson please go
watch it because he was the uncle that
just Cooks Burgers
anybody want horseradish
and it has Chadwick Boseman it has chat
real quick and this is a very practical
question okay especially for folks that
have seen them filmed twice now uh we've
talked about 2 hours 40 minutes you had
trailers on top of that that's three
hours if you're if you're grabbing have
a tasty beverage to drink during this
right unless you got a superhuman
bladder you might need to go pee during
this movie so is there a scene that
comes to mind that is like okay right
when this comes up
you can run out if you're back in 90
seconds you won't miss anything that'll
ruin the movie for you I know the scene
and also I thought of you because I
drank three cans of Sprite oh man three
cans of Sprite didn't leave once I don't
take this with a grain of salt as soon
as you see Nakia again
yeah yeah because like just all you need
to know is that Nakia gets recruited to
come back to a condo there's no other
important information that comes out
there some nice acting from Lupita
Nyong'o but I think that that's a good
one and it's about halfway and you see
here again and she recites exactly why
she doesn't show up to the funeral too
one thing I'll say is do not leave
during any underwater stuff no never
mind I'm a monster and I think all of
the dialogue is essential all of it so
I'd say like as soon as Sherry goes
underwater and it takes a while
it takes them like an hour and a half
and it has to have the jet stream
the songs
literally it takes the more he's like
we'll take the scenic route and I
respect that he's showing her off the
kingdom but you can go you can go and
come back with plenty of time
you get this sense of telecon without
having to take the the scenic route
it's a dialogue missed for all of our
blind viewers uh yeah there's not as
much for you to absorb then because it's
mostly the video description must be off
and also the songs
I'm just saying it's the only time you
don't have any plots I was gonna say if
you're gonna be really fast then maybe
right when the helicopter starts
arriving to the ship you got time
because by the time you get back you're
gonna see a jellyfish you're not gonna
miss much so oh oh yeah
during previews I know like it's been
out for a while but like do not go
during the anime on the last quantumania
trailer seeing that trailer on the big
screen yeah I was like it hit different
it was like that trailer is so good I
leaned over I was watching it with a
co-worker from new Rockstar so I was
like is Marvel making these trailers too
good like are they setting our
expectations unfairly High because we're
just talking about the kind of forever
first trailer because maybe one of the
best trailers I mean the the music and
the everything it's ridiculous and that
quantum Indian trailer is so good I
would almost go see a movie just if I
knew that was playing again but um okay
well I don't know if we got a different
answer on that but um I've got a thing I
definitely want to talk about because it
is my favorite scene element in maybe
any film this year uh like it is it is a
part of the movie that I think is very
unique to this film and it's very
especially bold for superhero film I
love the use of Silence in this film and
it's the first thing I brought up in my
non-spoiler review and it's the first
thing I thought the second time I
watched it and I loved that grief
is all-encompassing and that sorrow
feels heavy and that we live in a
society that is so stimulating and it's
a cacophony of Sight and Sound at all
times like Tick Tock is like you don't
get the first three seconds you're out
like there's a a world we live in that
is bombarding so any silence makes you
immediately introspective and it also
makes you immediately sometimes
uncomfortable and I thought the use of
Silence in this not only made us
reverent for Chadwick it also made us
uncomfortable in a way that made you
feel the grief because your your walls
drop immediately as soon as they're
silent it's like go in an elevator why
are elevators so uncomfortable because
it's silent so I love that Ryan coogler
was able to manipulate sound in a way
that it went from action action stimuli
oh my God so I'm immediately broken and
the movie opens beautifully with one of
the best Marvel fanfares I've ever seen
in a tribute to Chadwick that uses the
win from the end of the film so the very
last scene in the very first scene are
mirrors it's a bookend you get the wind
of her thinking and I I would argue the
last scene leading into the post-credits
scene the use of Silence there is
amongst my favorite sound design in a
film so I think the silence in this film
is the best character the MVP of this
film for me is the sound design
you heard me I know I did I sorry I
looked at a Super Chat that says Baku
can break my back
it was a super chat I'm sorry it's okay
I agree the silence in movies I is uh is
like a treat that we don't like uh we
don't consume enough and it it speaks so
much that intro with Chadwick Boseman I
was like why don't they do this more
often I was like why don't we give this
more often it hits harder when we see
that and then I was looking at every
little Marvel nook and cranny of the
lettering to be like this is where he
came from look at each one of these
parts of these movies that around phase
three and phase four and I was just like
I love this man so much and there's
different parts in the scene like the
bridge scene where the fighting is yeah
I noticed they had a lot of really
interesting it makes it feel like not
not the beginning of the Marvel but the
the bridge scene makes me feel like
they're dancing it feels like it's
authentic poetic and I say this again in
my review too that I'm like it's all
just poetic it's all beautiful and when
it's silent you really get a taste of
that I mean no [ __ ] on Thor four but
yeah look at the difference between the
rock and roll version of intro of the
Marvel Cinematic and we're like okay
this is a little bit different so when
that I remember that felt like you hit
the nail on the head it was
uncomfortable but in a in a way that you
know of to sit with your feelings and
your thoughts and and there were a lot
of moments I don't know about you guys
but in the theater there was so much
silence in the audience yeah and when
the credits hit and the Rihanna song
came on no clapping everyone was silent
just just watching and I remember
thinking like man this is so heavy yeah
you feel like a shell of a human right
yes it's an Infinity War I thought we'd
never get that kind of impact again
because the infinity War silence was
arguably 12 years of lead up right the
silence at the opening of this film is
our reality versus the MCU reality yeah
the silence you feel in the opening of
O'Connor forever is the Silence of our
respect for the real Chadwick Boseman
the silence at the end of infinity war
is our respect for characters that are
fictional right and I really appreciate
the fact that they were trusting the
audience to have respect for Chadwick
and t'challa do you understand how what
you I know you do I'm I'm saying this
because I feel like I'm at a church I
feel like I'm in church the how
beautifully Ryan cougar did it after
having to reconstruct everything and put
it out in less than two years yeah
exactly and it's so gorgeous it looks
like someone wrote a book and then
translated into a screenplay and came
out with it like seven or ten years
later and I'm like this is so insane but
it's so easy but it's also not it's when
I say it's easy it's like you see and
you're like oh yeah you can convey this
but also you can't right Google did a
really good job of diving into his own
heartbreak and putting it into the film
and now I've got a controversial take
I'm gonna kill you I I after I had to
deliver my favorite my favorite thing is
the silence I think that Namor in this
is the exact right name or for the film
I think the use of Namor for this story
is the exact correct thing I think the
use of this story was what we needed to
tell for wakanda I think the
storytelling in this is perfect but I
think that this is the most different a
comic character is from a movie
character that works but I did not sing
them more on that screen I saw the Logan
leader cuckoo con I don't think that
felt like Neymar more than 15 percent of
the time 85 percent of the time I was
like well this is wakanda's name or but
I never felt a sense of arrogance I felt
confidence I never felt a threat I felt
hosting he literally was like come see
my kingdom no more in in my mind you
should fear name or to the level that
you're confused that you want to like
him and at this characterization I'm
like if Sue storm leaves her kind of
absent-minded genius a little bit
cantankerous husband Reed Richards for
this guy I'm like good for her good
choice like he's someone that I'm like
like Sue deserves him he seems nice so
like I didn't work for me because I I
like wanted to be friends with them I
don't want to be friends with Neymar no
I feel like you wouldn't want to become
friends with this guy because the the
the it's not like I want to say
hot-headedness but it's just like the
immediate of just recognition of like oh
I gotta kill these people the the fact
that it was like a 360 of immediately
like no I'm gonna kill this little girl
and versus arrogant well no the thing is
how are you protecting by doing more
damage it feels like the killmonger
situation where it was like we gotta
kill him first before he gets us and
it's like okay but then that's 10
fingers pointing back at you that are
going to come back to you and your
nation you can kill all of wakanda but
then you think that the entire world
won't look for you so that's where I'm
like because you've already made the
blame Uncle he was very good about being
like they're gonna go after them I'm a
secret Nation so too but I just think
it's like oh no and not to cut you off I
meant that I don't think I think that's
still translated and I think there was
also needed for Ryan coogler to be like
you need to like this guy even though
he's bad and I think that's the part of
the comics that I think we did get was
the fact of like he is really bad and
not really bad I understand where his
justification is I love his
justification Ryan Cooper will always do
that for me but it's like it was so
quick and he didn't think about it and
he was just like no I just have to kill
them and you should be on our side or
you're gonna be my enemy he didn't
really it wasn't really not his
character something you can grow into
because again there's so much happening
in this movie I'm sure that they even
had time to to come up with a new origin
story come up with a new character
characterization and then still have a
this actor bring something near the
table was pretty impressive so maybe
like Loki in the first Thor to Avengers
there maybe they're they're gonna have
more of that later and I'm not I'm
certainly not disparaging the actor oh
it's a choice I literally think it's the
best choice for wakanda forever yes I'm
just acknowledging that usually when a
character and this is interesting
because it's adaptation versus
translation right the beautiful thing
about the Guillermo del Toro humble
movies is that they're adapted for
Guillermo like Hellboy in Guillermo's
Universe are those stunning Lush pair of
films the David Harbor film felt like
they were trying to translate the comic
fell flat because it was like why are
you trying to film a comic book you
can't film a comic book the beautiful
thing about comic books is the moment
you turn the page the moment you go from
panel to panel your imagination fills in
all the gaps you're living as the
Director the actor the cinematographer
the Curious like you're the Creator in
the comic books why I love them so much
when you're making a film you have to
somehow justify your personification of
the character in a way that translates
to the editor to the the actor to the
director to the Storyteller to everybody
so that's why these movies are so
magical is you're literally doing
Alchemy you're making gold out of so
many disparate Parts but rarely does it
work when the comic character that we
have such investment and as big as
nemour does feel so different so I'm
giving credit while acknowledging that
the whole time I was watching I was like
it's not my guy but I'm listening even
when he says imperious wrecks he says
itself I know I want him to be screaming
it was like the Avengers assembled when
she's like Avengers
I'll just throw out too I don't think
this movie is made for comic book fans
I think this movie needs to make a
billion dollars comic book sells 60 000
copies right like I think like this is
him saying like there's enough kind of
raw material there but I also I want
this to speak to like mesoamerica and
Indigenous peoples and it needs to be
like even just never saying wacconda
until somebody's taken out taking out
the Atlantis like sure that's like such
an important part of the character but
also like oh taking out Atlantis and
grounding it in something that it does
exist right like I think you maybe have
to lose some of that because also if you
want this guy to be the Black Panther
but for indigenous peoples and muscle
America like if you can't have him be an
[ __ ] yeah you know what I mean like
that's why I'm saying I was really happy
to be like I have both thoughts and it
didn't ruin my experience because a a
more immature thought process or even
like 10 years ago when comic films
weren't as common I'd have been like not
my name or but instead I'm like oh this
beautiful translation adaptation
experience this totally worked for me
over here yeah I would I would argue
it's better than the Comic version come
for me Marvel fans I don't care um uh
real quick I just want to shout out uh
somebody else that helps us we got we
got some uh Thomas and theories koi has
some other thoughts we're going to get
to and we again we want to get to all
your questions and thoughts real quick
but uh we want to shout out uh taking a
break from arvo briefly talk about DC's
Batman the audio Adventures that's
streaming on HBO Max yes uh an audio
series on HBO Max one with an incredible
cast Jeffrey Wright Jillian uh who's the
Jillian from community
Jacobs Jacobs thank you I almost said
Anderson from X-Files but that is she's
not in this show I hope that when they
were coming out with the movie They
accidentally tagged that yes
Rosario Dawson Chris Parnell incredible
cast it's streaming live on or it's
streaming the second season is streaming
on HBO Max you watch that and it's great
Jeffrey Wright actually plays Batman's
voice uh and covers kind of like all the
Rogues gallery that we love scarecrow
Catwoman uh harleen quinzel they're all
in there I know you got HBO Max you're
watching House of the Dragon you're
watching Euphoria you're watching you're
getting jazzed for succession season
four White Lotus is out right now uh
while you're watching those things hey
take some time maybe while you're
cooking and you can't watch the TV but
you want to be hearing some awesome uh
Batman content click over watch uh the
second season of DC's Batman the audio
Adventures streaming now on HBO Max
again that's DC's Batman the audio
Adventure streaming now on HBO Max
season one and two available
nice great well uh let's see
all right let's see so I have coming out
of the movie you know we all as you can
tell we all have a lot of opinions we
all love the movie and or maybe you did
it but it gave us a lot to talk about
and I left really with a lot of
questions about the culture of talukan
because again we had such a you know the
movie in all you know and all things
considered that this was a very short
movie to have so many things in it and
the fact that they were able to uh to
build out the world as much as they did
was amazing so let's talk about a little
bit of the talocon tolokan lore like
what is this deal about them maybe being
able to cheat death on the bridge
they made it a point to stop the movie
and tell the audience this is happening
this is weird but then it didn't really
come back I was thinking about that too
and is it and please correct me uh is it
because the fact that they ingested the
like vibranium soiled like the the plant
they underwater plant they like
physically ingested it like black
Panther kind of does because I was like
yeah this and then I guess over time
maybe that genetic makeup has changed
yeah because they are mutants now right
like they they all mutated or was it
nice well he's the mutants like mutants
yeah yeah oh yeah sorry sorry as in like
in the in the IRL sentence
so I could see them being uh maybe like
black panthers they we don't know like
how that works the ancestral plane right
black panther has access to death he has
access to that spiritual realm what if
their access is being connected to it by
living forever because the more mentions
that I have as many soldiers as Blades
of grass in wakanda that sounds to me
like people don't die if there's that
many people and three-quarters of the
planets underwater we don't know how big
that's just the capital city we don't
know how big this is his realm so there
could be billions of them because they
don't die and they last they live
forever right 1600s is not recent yeah
well he does though it's it I mean they
do die one got killed on screen right
with the Sonic Gun like she died before
her eyes so it is interesting it also
makes you wonder I think somebody
brought up before we were recording like
maybe they just are relatively immune to
vibranium she was all stabbing them with
her vibranium Spear and they kind of
shook that off but maybe they got shot
with the vibranium song
didn't seem to have any problems with
bullets too I guess so I keep grabbing
here because I agree with everything
you've said we talked about it again
sorry bring it up uh with Rogue theory
that I also think that it was a
situation of of maybe there are
gatherers and then there's the Warriors
or Fighters so it's like maybe this
woman didn't have the abilities that the
fighters do in the armies because we saw
there was different gender aside there's
men and women that were fighting on the
ship but some don't go so I was like
maybe there's some genetically that
Canada and the tumor was bulletproof but
not the minions around him right so
there was a little bit of that I don't
know because it was shooting off his arm
it was shooting oh so she was just
perfectly hitting the armor because the
other dudes at the chopper they were
getting they were getting they were
getting dropped quick but yeah a tuba
was just standing there and he's like
perfectly hitting all my shark teeth
like I I took it to mean that he was
maybe more invulnerable than the others
and so I wasn't really sure how that
went but obviously they have some extra
Powers I mean we've talked about the the
sound attacks that they do what's that
about
um you know now this ability to cheat
death and the other thing I was
wondering is uh you know because kind of
you can't help but look at it as a
mirror to the Aquaman franchisor on my
character so in Aquaman you know he
could very much talk to the animals you
know it's like and you can call them all
do does do they all talk to animals in
this because they're all riding the
humpback whales they're calling me like
there was a more open like yeah they all
communicate versus him being right I
mean a thing that I guess it's also like
I mean do do cowboys talk to horses well
the thing is you know maybe they're just
domesticated humpbacks you know what I
mean they've trained them right like I
mean well truly there's a different
impact with people and different like
any kind of spiritual animal so I think
they have a spiritual and mental
connection to these animals especially
because they're staying underwater with
these animals for x amount of years it's
like you learn to coexist and the more
probably started that thread so I'm
pretty sure that they're all just like
connected also or maybe it's like the
the Border tribe where they raised and
trained the Rhinos you're saying maybe
maybe they generationally yeah
they don't have like a psychic
connection with the Rhinos they've just
trained them like like again people
train horses or but there's a lot of
cultures that do believe that they have
psychic connections too or mental
connections two different animals and
there's a lot of there's a lot of cat
owners that believe that they have a
deep psychic connection to their cats
there you go
yeah uh I love that and again we we were
talking about like there's so much to
this culture and I like that they didn't
over explain very much of it you just
get hints you just get visual things you
just get like oh that's interesting they
didn't go into the details of of the
crazy siren Call thing that makes people
go to their death right we just saw it
once or twice and it was dope and like I
like that we didn't get a lot of
backstory there right and I want to
point out that that's really hard to do
to thread that needle of here's some
interesting things but it's not gonna
make you wonder like why the hell is
this is random why is this happening
like to leave the door open a little bit
to make you interested to want to learn
more but not to just flat out contradict
or have things seem to be there just for
for no reason other than the sake of
time in the movie it's a really
difficult task and again Ryan coogler
there you go uh and we had it we had a
couple other interlocking questions but
I want to get to some questions from the
audience here there's some really good
ones uh Bernard makui I'm sorry I'm
probably butchering your name there
Bernard but um uh during your interview
this is a question for Jessica what was
the question that you didn't get to ask
that you wish you did I really wanted to
know the backstories to atuma and nomura
and that was like the first question and
I was like because this might go over
the five minutes but I was like I
genuinely didn't get a lot of like
what's your relationship to the more and
I wanted to know what that relationship
was where it started especially for
those actors in their performance right
like because I mean you could look up a
comic book backstory or whatever but
like what are they taking into it right
specifically I wrote like what did Ryan
coogler tell you your connection was
um because it could be suicide I got too
nervous oh no no there's only so much
time but like also because like you
could see it being like Oh Soldier to a
general but you can also see it being
like um you know a God to a follower
right like this is my my Jesus my water
Jesus I interpreted the feathers that
the others wore that were like his
Travel Leaders is like an honorary thing
because of the feathers on his feet like
I saw it as like we're worshiping like
he's the God we don't have feathers
we're paying homage to him with these
ceremonious feathers and I love that
that mirrored the real cultures that
have feathers Wings yes but more so I
think the feather serpent God I think
yeah
right yeah because they need that cool
little rattlesnake sound I was like oh
that's why I had the name yes real quick
Mikey cheers wanted to know and I think
he's referring to when and again in a
brutal fight scene he gets one of his
four uh ankle uh wings uh ripped off by
Fury uh will that grow back
I think so 100 he's regenerative the
regenerative plus I mean like let's look
at the business side of things you gotta
you gotta fly I mean like if you're
gonna make
fish on a bike had a good one why didn't
shuri point out to Namor Namor uh that
Riri is just a brilliant student and not
actively searching for vibranium or
working with the government
um well I I think like one thing there
is because like that wouldn't have
mattered he doesn't care what her
motives are yeah he cares that she has
the knowledge to to make vibranium
detectors and anybody with that
knowledge needs to be murdered right
like you can't live anymore if you know
how to do that he did not care they were
like this is a young girl and he was
like the scientist must die yeah he did
not want any more information
she also yeah adding uh Pacific
Northwest that's right
um he sorry I was saying I don't know
why I was fishing on a bike I was
gendering you as is female but uh nerdy
by Nature do you think we could see
t'chella's son in the Young Avengers I
think that's a huge region you introduce
uh him in addition to obviously the the
connection to the character and like
having t'challa in the MCU being so
important but this is the youngest uh
character of the mall yeah toddler
Avengers almost yeah
but uh I feel like Eli Bradley are Eli
Bradley is one of the youngest right he
seemed like 12 or 13. yeah uh in in
Falcon Motorcycle
I thought it was like 16. well I guess
Tommy Tommy and Tommy and Billy are
probably oh wait no those kids are like
11.
don't we think we're getting recasted
Tommy and Billy yeah I don't think and I
don't know if they're gonna I thought
they're again but no matter what we got
at least a 10 year range right because
Kate Bishop is like 20. so even if if
Wanda and Billy are 11 that's a nine
year spread so I think it's very
possible that you know either a Kang
like I said we see him in the future or
we allow for Young Avengers to be a span
of Ages which I do think ties into the
whole kamala's law thing you need
someone very young and and Earnest and
and bright-eyed and bushy-tailed that
way if there's a threat you're like
there's children fighting yeah we don't
want that kid to die yeah yeah you need
there to be a person where you're like
that's inappropriate and Kate Bishop's
like I'm voting like she's she's not
younger yeah yeah I could maybe even be
surprising
some senses uh Quirk and Julia had a
great question did they get blipped into
local I mean half of all organisms
but they're in the universe so they must
have and they probably just assumed
something happened and then when
everyone came back they were like Okay
We're not gonna get them wait what
happened they probably morning if you've
been following we did an episode of the
break room last week where we talked
about like uh Ryan coolers talked a
little bit about his original plot for
this film before Chadwick's untimely
passing was going to involve it was
still going to involve grief it was
going to involve him dealing with the
grief of losing half of his people
getting them back but still like what's
that done to the country so you could
see like that being a motivator from the
more too and that version of the script
um Abe the Archer saying was that bossed
that sure we saw and not ramonda is that
like when she had this yeah I love that
also the quick mention of best uh when
is when she
she says okay the second mentioning
about was when she was about to go into
the ancestral plane and uh Lupita Nakia
said
um only got only boss can know how to do
this with in a science lab yes and I
would love for nothing more for Angela
Bassett to be the like representation of
a boss is but I do think we did see bass
technically in store love and thunder
but I would love for that
that love for Angela yeah that would be
so bad yeah like the Mother Earth but
for wakanda right yeah I love it do you
think uh nick uh marmalejo saying uh do
you think Neymar Neymar is playing the
part to use wakanda later for sure
yeah he said something he drew on that
wall and said I'm coming back I speak to
what you were saying with like I might
get the more comic like and I'm very
open-minded too but that would be how we
get like maybe he's like well I've
already manipulated the greatest land
Nation now I'm in that country and maybe
now he's like he has even more to lose
he's also been whooped right he's like
maybe had a hit to his pride maybe he
does turn a little darker maybe on
future things he could also go the
opposite and be like a better dude right
I can't wait till he has to because they
mention Ryan coogler mentioned how he's
like a strongest Thor in the Hulk and
when he has to go against the Thor or
the Hulk is going to be the day of
recording like we said he's going to be
like Thor meet me in this pool okay
we're not they're fighting in Scottsdale
they ain't fighting yeah
asking what happened to the queen really
threw me off anybody else shocked at a
certain moment oh hell yeah yes that
moment it was like there's still more
lost like I almost couldn't handle it I
was like how much is there on this show
we said who's gonna die and I said
Ramona
I said it would be her because I was
like it can't be embaku I don't think we
got enough of him and I was like I don't
think he's gonna be in Ikea and I was
like it's either gonna be ramonda
and look at what we got it looked like
for a moment it was going to be aquarium
on that bridge I thought like oh are
they about to kill a koi like yeah when
uh yeah one interesting thing again
another Thor parallel in the sequel
movie uh the queen dies because Thor's
mom died in the third world and yeah
obviously the post-credits scene like
with with young prince when you see his
silhouette in the background I
immediately gasp like the moment you see
her holding hands with somebody's
wearing yeah
and then my second viewing are you
talking about the first time you saw him
at the school for yeah so the second
time I watched it he's the kid that says
hi that brings him to Nakia he's
literally he's my grandma and he reached
her like they like very comfortably and
then when she mentions like have you met
him like they'd clearly met there was a
familiarity in Haiti which I love
bonjour there's also another little part
where right at the river when they're
talking with the elephant she was about
to tell yeah she was about to tell
Sherry about uh yeah
there are so many I loved when I saw the
second time and I saw the school and he
said do you want to see the head
mistress I was like you didn't even say
grandma
well also he he didn't say grandma
because like he also knows she's there
undercover he's undercover yes he
doesn't want to out himself as the
prince of wakanda is his head Mistress
of no familiarity yeah yeah
um uh Theodore Harrison killmonger
refers to the chalocons as the Lost
tribe I thought you thought that was
interesting that is interesting I
thought he was referring to someone else
as the Lost tribe no no they no they
were they were yeah I mean and it's
interesting because his whole thing is
about like uh a people being conquered
right things being taken over if you
look at what the locals dealt with they
literally had to restrate to the ocean
like they had they lost their land they
lost what that was so I could see that
being a larger commentary on like you
know the the end of the movie In Black
Panther one he wants to be killed he
wants to he doesn't want to live in
shackles he doesn't want to live on that
ship being taken to be as a slave so I
could see the loss of their property
being a very impactful thing to
killmonger so I mean at that moment
seeing it that's shocking moment when
they turned the corner and we saw
Michael Jordan looking like the comic
which made me happy I'd love to see more
of what killmonger perceives wakanda as
I saw that bun and I said that's
killmonger I was literally like that's
killmonger no but also that line of like
the Lost tribe I think I also like the
if it is symbolism to like they don't
know
I wish I was gonna say the uh like going
like just immediately killing people is
like not the way to go so he's like yeah
they're a little lost right now yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
he said bring me that little child I'm
going to murder her all right I took
that to be a reference to like the lost
city of Atlantis because they're trying
to because this isn't Atlantis
real quick uh Corey can drilly sending a
Super Chat their effect his effects
company did the Boston chase scene
Kudos on you uh you Capri to singing and
sending a Super Chat uh rip to Batman
hell yeah morning until we join you and
Kevin conright uh Max Lee saying uh love
koi in his jacket hell yeah show the
folks that snazzy Jack is actually from
the fine folks at box lunch and every
ten dollars you spend at box lunch feeds
someone a person in need so literally
supporting your fandom also supports
people that need it most I just did a
charity event with them they spent 150
million people uh they are one of the
most incredible companies and their
merch is actually like this is high
quality and it's legit like uh Brandon
said it doesn't like fade and one watch
but they they literally feed people with
Phantom so check out boxlunchgifts.com
some of the best people I've ever worked
with I love them much and I love this
jacket so thank you oh yeah box lunch
come on the show uh you can pray it's
also saying uh we're in a diaper don't
go pee wear a diaper I agree I agree I
drink three cans of soda and I was oh
use your cup a lot of water in that
movie I know I don't I don't know if
there's a film that I'm willing to sit
in my own urine for I'm not sure this
movie
water that you're such a liar I know
there's a I'm trying to think of like
okay there are a couple movies
not short oh that's true I'd be in my
pants for any game
yeah
Fernando Escobar saying Angela B Oscar
buzz I mean he doesn't get nominated I
hope so I will lose more faith than I
already have my faith in the Academy
Awards is already at zero but if they
don't nominate her it'll go down to a
negative yeah she was great and she also
like they clearly gave her like her
thing at the U.N her moment of chewing
out of koi she had like three or four
just showcase scenes and they were like
I I feel like Ryan cougar was like eat
it up go ahead do whatever you want
because that you win speech was like her
body she kept moving her arms when she
talked and looking left and right with
her eyes and I was just like she's just
dancing her traps are threatening also
that woman she was on screen don't don't
Google Angela bassett's age or you'll
feel awful about yourself okay
it showed up randomly on like my for you
page her workout routine which is does
it have actual like exercises like
specific she she works out like twice a
day too much and I'm like you she looks
incredible I mean not only obviously
she's in incredible shape uh for anybody
any age but then like again she deserves
to be fresh face Friday every day every
day of the week um every hat they put
her in I was like yeah looked great
there's so much more we could say we
appreciate everybody that's been thrown
in questions uh there's so many more
questions luckily we got all next week
if you think we're done talking about
wakanda forever you got another thing
coming because we could talk about
wakanda forever that's right um but
um thank you so much for tuning in thank
you for uh enjoying again we've got our
ending explained video from mt's already
up on the channel Jessica's uh
non-spoiler review is already out uh of
course you could be spoiled now but um
and then our full movie breakdowns
coming out on the channel tomorrow we'll
have all kinds of what kind of content
coming out uh from the break room from
new rock stars in general all the rest
of the week you should uh follow these
folks on social media follow at new
rockstars and we're putting up some fun
Instagram content and Twitter stuff over
the weekend as well uh like this video
subscribe and you know what have
yourself a blessed weekend everybody get
some rest
[Music]
thank you